It’s no secret that people love theorizing
and speculating about Star Wars.
And with new movies coming out every year
for the foreseeable future, there’s no shortage
of discussions to be had.
Even before The Force Awakens, the franchise
had numerous questions that were never answered,
and now with an all-new canon that includes
novels, comics, and TV shows, just about anything
is possible.
As we wait to see what the future films have
in store, here are 10 Star Wars mysteries
that can’t be answered (so far).
Is Kylo Ren Redeemable?
Darth Vader’s arc in the classic trilogy
was turning back to the light side through
his relationship with Luke, so viewers are
wondering if something similar is in store
with Kylo Ren.
The new villain is obviously torn between
the two sides of the Force and seeks to consume
himself in the darkness.
He even commits an ultimate act of evil when
he murders his father, Han Solo.
For fans, that’s an unforgivable transgression
and the filmmakers seem to be setting up Ben
Solo as someone who cannot be saved.
That would be a nice change-of-pace for the
franchise, but it’s still early to say for
sure.
Who Is Snoke?
Given J.J. Abrams’ shaky history with keeping
character names a secret, many were convinced
that Episode 7’s Supreme Leader Snoke wasn’t
really Snoke.
From the moment the character was announced,
theories ran rampant, with the common belief
being that he is Darth Plagueis, the Emperor’s
former master.
Though, in the finished film, there’s no
misdirection with his identity.
Still, questions about Snoke have only increased
since Force Awakens’ premiere, and there’s
sure to be more of his backstory revealed
in the coming episodes.
At the very least, how he rose to power is
a subject worth exploring.
What Is Luke’s Mission?
The opening line from the Episode 7 text crawl
informed fans that hero Luke Skywalker has
vanished, and both the First Order and the
Resistance are searching for him.
Since his screentime in Force Awakens is all
too brief, why Luke disappeared is something
not really touched upon.
It sounds like it was Ben Solo’s turn to
the Dark Side that forced Luke into isolation,
but that doesn’t explain what Skywalker
was trying to accomplish.
Why he chose Ahch-To and what he intends to
do while there is something fans are dying
to know, and with Mark Hamill getting a meatier
role in Episode 8, they’ll most likely learn
the answers.
Forgetting the Droids
By including R2-D2 and C-3PO in the prequel
trilogy, George Lucas created some retroactive
plot holes in the originals.
Chief among them is the oddity that nobody
recognizes the droids, despite having multiple
interactions with them.
C-3PO served on the Lars family farm years
before the Jawas sold him to Uncle Owen, and
R2-D2 served with the Republic in the Clone
Wars, fighting alongside Obi-Wan Kenobi.
They could just be playing dumb, but it creates
an unnecessary distraction when watching the
complete saga.
Unlike droids, humans seemingly can’t have
their memories erased, so their forgetting
fairly recognizable droids is a head-scratcher.
What Happened to the Ewoks?
Without the Ewoks, the Rebel Alliance may
not have won the Battle of Endor to defeat
the Empire, meaning they were a huge part
of the original trilogy.
So what happened to them?
Due to the Death Star exploding right over
the forest moon, some say that the species
experienced a nuclear winter and faded into
extinction following their celebration.
That’s a bit dark for Star Wars, and even
though the Ewoks aren’t beloved, fans hope
their fate is a little more pleasant than
that.
Hopefully they’re mentioned in a canon book
so those who do enjoy them can get some peace
of mind.
Who Is Ben Mendelsohn Playing?
Talented character actor Ben Mendelsohn was
a great addition to the Star Wars universe,
and many fans are excited to see him play
the main villain in Rogue One.
Just as they did with The Force Awakens, Lucasfilm
is keeping the new character names largely
under wraps; meaning the identity of his character
is still a mystery.
The only clue is his Imperial uniform, which
strongly resembles that of a Grand Admiral.
Could Mendelsohn be playing the canonical
version of EU evildoer Grand Admiral Thrawn,
someone people want to see in the movies.
His physical appearance is different from
the blue alien, but he’s obviously an important
figure.
Who is Jyn Erso?
The Rogue One trailer revealed that Felicity
Jones is playing Jyn Erso, but her introduction
is somewhat confusing.
She’s being escorted through a Rebel base
in handcuffs before receiving an assignment
from Mon Mothma.
Originally, viewers believed that all the
heroes would already be affiliated with the
Rebel Alliance, but it looks like Jyn is being
recruited to the cause and is a newcomer.
Her backstory will be interesting to learn,
given her importance in the Galactic Civil
War.
Why the Rebels seek Jyn out despite her criminal
record is a big question, and hopefully the
film has a good reason for it.
The New Stormtroopers
Rogue One features more than just the classic
stormtrooper design, showcasing all-new Death
Troopers decked in black, as well as ones
with tan armor.
Their inclusion is somewhat surprising, since
these soldiers are not featured in the three
installments of the classic trilogy.
Their inclusion has raised some questions
as to why that is, with one possible answer
being that they are plot-specific and are
not needed in the main saga.
While it isn’t a huge deal, it would be
nice to see the film provide some kind of
explanation as to why these new stormtroopers
are needed and why they disappear from the
fight afterwards.
Is Vader in Rogue One?
It’s long been rumored that Darth Vader
would make his big screen return to wreck
havoc in Rogue One, but the teaser did not
make any mention of the Sith Lord.
Choosing to spotlight the new characters,
some fans have started to wonder if it’s
a sign that Vader will not be in the spinoff.
With Ben Mendelsohn’s character being positioned
as the chief antagonist, it is a possibility.
On the other hand, Lucasfilm waited until
the second Force Awakens trailer to show Han
Solo and Chewbacca, so they could be holding
back for a great reveal.
Star Wars sells itself after all, there’s
no need to rush.
Who are Rey’s Parents?
Sequel trilogy protagonist Rey has a mysterious
backstory that will most definitely be explored
in the upcoming installments.
Since fans first saw her, they’ve been wondering
who her parents are.
Since the numbered episodes chronicle the
Skywalker family saga, the most prevalent
theory is Rey is Luke’s daughter.
That may be too obvious, but there’s enough
evidence to support it.
It’s frustrating for viewers to be left
in the dark, but it gives the upcoming movies
material to explore and the filmmakers have
promised a satisfying answer.
After all, nobody knew Luke’s true heritage
until The Empire Strikes Back, so it’s best
to let it all play out.
Those are our picks for Star Wars mysteries
that haven’t yet been solved (but could
be soon).
Are there any we missed?
Which ones do you want answered?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos like this one!